allez bonsoir à vous et bienvenue dans
ce set 8 spéciales fêtes de fin d'année
suivez moi autour de la table il ya
plein de monde on va recevoir des
invités il y aura des reportages nos
journalistes qui ont pris tous les
risques et bonsoir à vous bonsoir
clermont sera yolaine non ça aurélia
bonsoir olivier bon savon tony ce que
vous connaissez de la rédaction bonsoir
natalia vous êtes conteuse et vous
accompagnerez pendant cette partie des
missions et puis bon sens il faut qu'on
me dise ah bah non c'est quand même très
bien et on va commencer tout de suite
alors j'ai pour débuter j'aimerais vous
montrer une image c'est dans les
yvelines on sait comment célébrer noël
dans les yvelines vous allez voir c'est
à montigny le bretonneux avec ceux
particuliers qui a tout simplement
recycler son camping-car qui lui sert
pas forcément beaucoup en hiver en
crèche géante et oui ça fait sourire
autour de la table olivier je vois que
vous prenez des exemples vous à les
reproduire
un peu plus d'enthousiasmé quand même la
chance aux particuliers qui a joliment
des colonies contre une carte blanche
car forcément les rois mages ça va plus
vite en camping tout à fait alors dans
un sens on justement olivier on va voir
comment écoute un simple oui à vous nous
raconterez parce que c'est pas si simple
que ça mais avant de commencer on va
tout d'abord à écouter quelques micros
trottoirs vos souvenirs de fêtes de fin
d'année un nouvel an plein de plein de
monde et c est ma fille trois ans s'est
trompé en un jus d'orange et un punch et
bien sûr elle a été malade toute la
soirée donc une bonne anecdote elle s'en
rappellent encore et maintenant elle a 9
ans elle avait trois ans l'époque
j'avais dit que j'allais un petit besoin
pressant et puis je vais suivi de
m'habiller je vais me le pantalon je
veux mula var l'élu met les lunettes qui
clignote le bonnet et puis aussitôt
après page sur les jeux se déshabiller
et donc les fiches valliot papilles à
terme elle qui est passée aujourd'hui je
n'ai pas vu je les loupés quelqu'un
qu'on attendait pas du tout et la part
du pauvre a pris son sens total et on
était heureux de faire une surprise à un
voisin qui passait à l'improviste voilà
non il venait de dire bon noël et puis
on lui a proposé de rester on savait pas
que cette personne là était seule chez
elle ce soir là vous souvenir avant 81
piège
non mais moi j'ai rencontré vraiment
maintenant c'est le papa qui vous d'y
renoncer serait trop long et on a crevé
on n'a que cinquante deux minutes ont
suffi à tour à tour sa table un souvenir
de noël forcément posé comme sa personne
et
l'émission allez on cotise émission on
va aller on va aller du côté saint
lambert des bois on va assister un
massacre
non c'est pas sa masse il a fait ça bien
l'olivier et oui je sais qu'il a fait ça
vient à la basse à regarder moi chez
daniel barbier je me suis rendu à la
sapinière barbier en fait moi je suis
très heureux à tv film est bon
voilà mais bon vous savez ce que c'est
c'est la crise il faut arrondir les fins
de mois je me suis trouvé un petit
boulot je suis devenu very own câlinerie
en
l'espace d'un instant je suis devenu un
vendeur de sapins donc c'est le choix du
sapin c'est la découpe du sabbat le
voilà dix ans fils et j'ai tout est-il
vraiment élevé c'est de regarder les
oliviers bûcheron
bon allez y vit avec il ya des clients
qui arrivent ah ouais voilà que les
accueillent bonjour
j'ai volé c'est mon vendeur l'a alors je
suis un nouveau vendeur voilà je viens
d'arriver j'ai eu une formation avec
alain daniel une formation rapide
je vais essayer de vous aider qu'est ce
qui vous fait rêver c'est d'abord
un norman a alors je vous accompagner
donc les nordmann à pêche et la pige
tendon voilà comment ce bien c'est pas
grave
je prends donc mes premiers clients en
main mais avant de débuter ma carrière
de vendeur daniel le patron m'a appris
deux ou trois choses à savoir la pige
tout d'abord cette longue barre gratuit
et sert à mesurer les sapins elle peut
aller jusqu'à 6 mètres un petit tableau
me servira à connaître l'état des sapins
selon leur variété et leur taille avec
ou sans socle est un petit tour de la
sapinière va m'aider à repérer où sont
les nordmann les épicéas et les nobilis
sans oublier les petits rubans qui
signale les arbres déjà vendus voilà je
suis fort mais maintenant il faut
qu'ils en
aient bien d'arriver le pauvre ça va de
la ville heures
c'est à cet album les gamins qui
cherchent à s'en passer
cécile vous fait penser c'est magique
l'air de bien celui-là c'est brouille de
côté
bien proportionnée
oui allez bon ben voilà on pense que oui
on la laisse un peu tourné alors
avec le pied du dégage un peu ok tu
recherches le pied de sapins ouais
battu la côte par terre tu remontes un
cheval a tu remontes hachoud et que
combien droit accélère
voilà c'est bon
mais pour l'arrêter
attente d'un nouveau moteur
est
parti
trop loin
merci beaucoup samuel et bah merci
beaucoup les coupes une décoration du
sapin je le souhaite merci au revoir
bon bah daniel ça s'est bien passé bah
qu'est ce que tu en penses c'est bon
est-ce que je suis pris dans l'équipe
ben ouais c'est pas mal quand même une
première fois c'est pas mal surtout la
tronçonneuse faut faire très attention
non non c'est on sent tata du tas du
commercial talus enfin bon il n'y a pas
de problème par contre on a un petit
truc c'est la tradition une transition
pas une petite tradition il faut passer
allah
les
bouchers votre sapin vous allez venir
avec cette fois la coupe est anthony va
vous aider en tout cas on peut juste
dire qu entre journalisme et sapinière
ici en tout cas un lien c'est le mot
pigeons c'est un magnifique norman de 2
m 20 voilà écoute je crois aux alentours
de 90 euros si ma mémoire est bonne
on a eu un petit rabais nous on a eu un
petit rab et on a eu un petit sourire un
petit prix spécial et voilà un
magnifique sapin magnifiquement décorée
et puis voilà je vais continuer
vous avez des clients
alors le nordmann c'est pour tous ceux
et toutes celles qui font le ménage
c'est celui qui ne perd pas forcément
c'est étonnant voilà donc ça c'est
vraiment pratique mais après l'épicéa
sans plus le sapin si vous aimez la
bonne heure du sapin épicéa c'est
recommandé voilà c'est un peu la
différence majeure
l'autre question peut-être
expliquer à tronçonner parce que pour la
machine c'est assez dangereux voix vous
avez pris tous les risques c'est assez a
b c est impressionné par olivier
pas impressionné le quatrième
non en fait il ya une technique voilà
comme on le voit un peu dans le jeu
testé avec une jambe on essaie de
est-ce que vous pouvez refaire ce qu'on
avait deux joueurs étoiles pour une fois
un mouvement de janvier un mouvement jam
en fait il faut écarter les branchages
avec
l'enjeu
et après moi effectivement faire
attention quand le tronc est coupé de ne
pas continuer ce coupé
honda monte souvent sur les poneys vu
comment vous le faites bien sûr le coin
activement j'ai d'ailleurs demain soir g
phone et c'est vrai
merci olivier alors cette foire nathalie
à notre compte tout ce qui est en
plateau avec nous vous êtes impressionné
non
natalia nathalie natalia natalia vous
êtes sentosa vous n'êtes pas contre eux
tout seuls emprunts si vous êtes de il
ya irène qui est avec vous mais là ce
soit en plateau vous êtes vous êtes tout
seul et vous vous appelez les tirs
cheville est le nom est amusant pourquoi
les tirs se lier à les rapports avec le
char perron bien sûr c'est la référence
à charles perrault et puis c'est une
façon d'ouvrir les portes des comptes
donc c'est en référence à la célèbre
phrase de tir la chevillette et la
bobinette cherra du petit chaperon rouge
que tout le monde connaît voilà ça
permet d'entrer dans l'univers des
contes voilà pourquoi nous avons choisi
ce se noue alors en ce moment vous
intervenez au château de breteuil nous
intervenons aussi dans les lits you take
aider et les médiathèques et puis vous
êtes fait une spécialité parce que c'est
le moment des contes de noël mais les
contes de noël du monde entier oui voilà
nous emmenons les enfants dans le monde
entier avec quatre contes un conte russe
un conte italien un compte suisse pour
les crottes en chocolat et le dernier un
conte africain mais dans chacun de ces
pays ont raconté à peu près noël de la
même manière absolument la trame des
comptes est identique on retrouve
exactement la même trame par exemple le
conte russe et bien c'est en référence
également à un conte de charles perrault
les faits il retrouve exactement les
mêmes personnages alors vous allez nous
dire un petit extrait alors je vais vous
raconter des nouradons désir de moussa
du petit moussa voilà du petit moussa je
vous emmène en afrique le petit moussa
vit avec sa grand mère dans une petite
maison au bord de la route avant le
grand désert et
ils reçoivent chez eux toutes sortes de
voyageurs de berger qui se perd qui
perdent leur chemin et c'est l'occasion
pour le petit moussa d'écouter toutes
sortes d'histoires du monde entier cette
nuit là c'est la nuit de noël la
grand-mère de moussa lui a préparé une
bonne soupe à la viande parce que la
soupe à la viande ce fait grandir les
enfants et ça réchauffe le coeur alors
ils n'ont pas beaucoup d'argent mais
elle a mis tout son coeur pour faire
cette soupe et ce soir là ils reçoivent
trois invités surprises un prince un
berger et un gros monsieur avec une
barbe blanche et chacun d'entre eux va
offrir un petit cadeau magique à moussa
une toupie qui fait envoler la peur une
un futur qui fait envoler la tristesse
et la cuillère en bois qui permet
d'avoir la soupe de son choix l'année
ball boli la grand-mère de moussa et
mousse avons passé le plus beau noël de
leur vie le gros monsieur repart le
premier vous l'aurez sûrement reconnu en
on sait qu'il aura
plein sens du mot l'a reconnu mais qui
fuit qu'est ce qui vous plaît merci
natal est mais qu'est ce qui me plaît
dans ce sens de perrault
ce qui nous plaît c'est la magnifique
langue de charles perrault actuellement
on a trop tendance à raconter les
versions des frères grimm et puis on
sans compter les les version disney qui
sont vraiment très très éloigné de de
perrault et nous devons remettre bien
sûr pour faire présenter au public la
belle langue de charles perrault est
également son humour qui est très
présent dans tous ces contes et des
histoires qu'on vous racontez vous êtes
ultime ouais tout le monde connaît
cendrillon la belle au bois dormant les
parties poussé à part cela on fait le
truc qui vont nous raconter une histoire
alors pourquoi quand à des coupes mais
on fait aussi des devinettes oui bon on
ponctuent notre spectacle de noël par
des devinettes pour les enfants j'en ai
apporté deux minutes ces niveaux en
trépigne du point
voilà attention
vous êtes tous sur la main sur le buzzer
où habite le faire n'aurait trois
propositions pour 123 pour vous dire
plus sur la lune au pôle nord ou affiche
toujours une
réponse
deuxième devinettes comment le père noël
entre-t-il dans les maisons il passe par
les troncs des souris il a les clés de
toutes les maisons du monde ils passent
par là chez nous avec ce joli les
clichés mais chez
moi je
passe toujours par la cheminée tant pis
pour ceux dont on ne peut pas changer
l'histoire c'est que c'était cool etc
les maisons du
ccs qui lors du chocolat longtemps
énormément
c'est pour ça qu'il a beaucoup nous
allons fabriquer par la cheminée
oui ça c'est super your head on sait pas
si vous passez par la cheminée mais en
tout cas vous avez mangé du chocolat si
vous l'avez fabriquer aussi exactement
c'est pour ça que je me suis rendu chez
franck dobosz à un grand chocolatier qui
a accepté de
vous faire part de ses petits secrets
pour fabriquer le chocolat vous qui m'a
fait fabriquer des boules de noël des
petites boules de noël vous avez envie
je ne sais pas
et oui aujourd'hui tablier je vais
tester pour vous collomb fraise et
chocolat avec un gros chocolatière
bonjour bonjour accueillir chez vous
fait plaisir alors vous allez
confire aux petits secrets de gros
chocolatier qu'est ce qu'on va faire
aujourd'hui on va faire des boules d'un
côté four et caramel et de l'auto
fourrés praliné qu'est ce qui fait que
votre chocolat est absolument fabuleux
il ya des dosages particulier
en fait nos chocolats sont fabuleux
parce que déjà on travaille qu'avec des
produits frais nous avons des noisettes
romaine ce sont des noisettes qui sont
près de rome et pour le prime et 6 et
les noisettes que je préfère
là on va prendre ce moule on va déjà
faire une première couche au pinceau
c'est une fine couche de chocolat et on
l'a cette machine qu'est ce que c'est
long tout à l'heure cette machine c'est
la machine au chocolat ou les le faire
au format 5 à 45 degrés le rabaisser à
26,27 est remonté à 29 si on respecte
pas ce que vaut température le chocolat
ça n'ira pas il sera qui va passer des
moules et il a il va pas durcir qui va
être il va fabrier ça va pas aller alors
que je passe en dessous
et je vais direct
saison
et voilà à pékin
continue
en fait celui-ci avec la
servez maps et d'amour
oui
coulanges prochaine je jouerai
voilà
branchée
ça va allez
c'est parti
on va la garder
principe comparaison
eh bien ça
à la fin on verra bien
belle victoire
il faut demander de nous là
les électeurs voilà nikkei après on est
comme ça voilà un titre qui fuit
d'ailleurs non c'est pour moi un bon
niveau
ces moments fatidiques attention
mesdames et messieurs
que dis je
j'attends toujours
embauches viennent en tant que
chocolatière
passionné c'est pour
vous le débat est dans la boîte entre le
ce qui est plaisant de le goûter des
fêtes passées dans son composent à
commencer par l'invité hier lé va
commencer par les jeux vraiment vous à
tout le monde les aura vu personne
n'attendait ça fait dix jours qu'on les
cherche partout dans la rédaction et
rennes les avait bien caché son jeu si
c'est par visionnage et si vous êtes
malade c'est violer
c'est justement c'est un sujet demandé
si on pouvait faire ça chez moi et m'a
dit que c'était un peu compliqué parce
que justement c'est une question de
dosage de température du chocolat qui
durcit assez vite gràce à la grosse
machine justement qu'on a vu sur nos
vies sur les images
sa patronne à une partie caramel partie
pradinois grand voile à sa sortie dans
les leurres d'orient
avec la gantoise
était plus personne me sourire jusqu à
la fin de l'émission on rayait notre
nouvelle spécialistes chocolat ou à des
questions très pertinentes ils doivent
se
produire à la maison comment s'est
passée dans un bouge comme là c'est pas
possible
merci sont pas très c'est une journée
d'audition mais après le prochain sujet
avait alors le sujet alors on va quitter
le niveau du chocolat anthony je me
tourne vers vous et vous êtes venus sont
vos plumes oui mais j'ai mon petit
shorty en dessous six mois mais ça se
passe après l'émission grecque cet
espace catherine antoine ab mission et
anthony vous êtes quand même très
gourmand oui donc
découvrir l'endroit peut-être le plus à
l'ancienne un cabaret à l'ancienne dans
versailles a plus besoin d'aller sur les
champs-elysées pour voir des danseuses
un spectacle un petit peu comme dans les
années comme on monte dans les danseuses
chanteuses de jazz et autres styles de
nelly on en faisait dans les années 50
en fait donc je vous propose une visite
guidée du mis leurs adversaires
nous nous trouvons à quelques centaines
de mètres du château de versailles
derrière moi un lieu atypique le milord
un cabaret à l'ancienne dans les caves
de la ville du roi soleil suivez moi
pour la visite guidée
les loups beaufort grands soirs antonier
bienvenue aux millar merci de nous
accueillir dans ce lieu si beau et
atypique de versailles un cabaret un
petit peu à l'ancienne comme on n'en
fait plus tout d'abord première question
qui me brûlait un petit peu les lèvres
en entrant et quel est le concept du
milord par le concept c'est un piano bar
cabaret comme on en fait peu maintenant
où plusieurs artistes vont défiler
chaque soir avec une programmation
différente du jeudi au samedi
et donc voilà essayer de remettre en
scène la caméra elle est au cabaret
parisien avec al bared l'a toujours
alors c'est une affaire que vous avez
repris il ya quelques mois cet été
exactement pourquoi avoir choisi de
reprendre le lion alors je suis danseuse
et chorégraphe à la base un métier que
j'exerce et rend plus de vingt années
donc voilà en l'envi encore de revivre
cette passion le miller à versailles je
crois aussi que c'est quand même un lieu
un petit peu chargé d'histoire même si
le kabary en lui-même et a été créée en
2009 avant il ya une autre vie et notre
vie où on sent qu anna hier par un an
ici alors au temps des rois je ne fais
pas mais en tout cas oui tout quartier
saint louis a été un petit peu sur ce
thème est donc maintenant on essaye
plutôt de d'avancé de mettre en scène le
jazz puisque autre chose quoi voilà je
vous propose d'aller découvrir le
spectacle bal avec plaisir
à
oh
le coup
ah ah
vous le voyez dans le milord tout est un
peu étriqué à l'image de ces escaliers
nous allons retrouver dans coin cuisine
tout aussi petit didier qui est le co
gérant mais qui s'affairent en cuisine
aux fourneaux on va aller le voir un peu
ce qu'ils préparent pour les clients ici
nous traversons la loge c'est par ici
on va on va regarder un petit peu vos
oeuvres qu'est ce que vous préparez de
bon là pour vos premiers clients voilà
je prépare une sarladaise la saladelle
c'est une des assiettes préféré notre
clientèle qu'elle soit base de foie gras
avec confiture de figues c'est servir
des taux salarié doit et et salades et
pommes de terre avec quelques petites
amendes etc garni de de magret de canard
tranché c'est le rêve
vous êtes cuisinier à la base ou pas du
tout c'est une vocation que vous êtes en
train de faire naître un petit peu je ne
suis pas cuisinier à la base je ne fais
que des choses que j'aime un peu et il
se trouve que nos clients de rossi a
bien à l'écouté ça alors à côté des
clients merci didier merci beaucoup
à chaque configuration de salle en
fonction du nombre de gens on doit
éviter les têtes évitez les pieds de
chaise c'est à chaque fois c'est unique
en fait c'est juste très agréable et
très atypique et que la triste dans une
cave voûtée proche des gens on peut
vraiment créer une ambiance cabaret
chantant on a le ressenti on a des
demandes de si particulière à faire
certaines personnes demandent certaines
chansons et avec plaisir si elles font
partie du répertoire je les fais avec
grand plaisir
la chanteuse est excellente il heureux
quoi et vous osez rien non j'ai vu ses
yeux
on est là en amour j'ai pas trop osé
didier merci pour cette visite guidée du
milord et pour l'accueil aussi je vois
que vous êtes en train de faire la
plonge on va vous laisser tranquillement
finir la soirée et puis reprendre le
matériel vous avez terminé votre visite
guidée parce qu'en fait il restait un
dernier chose à voir laquelle loi et
bats la vaisselle ah bon mais ça fait ça
fait partie ça fait partie du jeu
l'ambiance générale c'est vrai c'est
vrai alors et alors vous les sanctionner
vous avez été d'excellents clients votre
coupe de champagne était bonne et je
vous propose de vous en acquitter en
avant ces quelques assiettes à faire le
tester pour vous jusqu'au voilà
un jeu de coeur à l'ouvragé c'est parti
merci à voile le champagne je vous en
prie
on va débriefer dans un instant cette
séquence avec anthony rech qui était
donc aux mille ordre à versailles avec
l'ensemble de l'équipe de téléphiles
également merci à notre invité de cette
première partie d'émission natalia qui
nous racontait ses jolis contes tout à
l'heure un peu de publicité la suite du
7-8 noël tout de suite après
et on se retrouve sur le plateau du 7-8
spécial fêtes de fin d'année avec
l'ensemble de la rédaction de tv fil 78
d'anthony on vous a laissé venir en
bonne compagnie
avant juste avant parce que tout à
l'heure on parlait de chocolat et oui il
en reste un chocolat un seul et la
finlande le chocolat qui reste voilà
porter en régime réclame 6,3 en régie à
tout à l'heure tout à l'heure où fried
oui alors se dire en charmante compagnie
d'anthony oui vous étiez pas tout seul
quand même pour réaliser ce nom gilles
faut peut-être saluer aussi votre
acolyte et mon acolyte le notre
journaliste reporter d'image un jonathan
wiedemann qui a fait d'eux un très beau
travail une fois de plus on a fini très
tard ce soir là que je veux vous
rassurer tout le spectacle est ce qui
est le plus étonnant quand même dans la
performance des danseuses c'est le
manque d espace elle danse sur un mètre
cinquante de large un tout petit couloir
entre les tables et vraiment c'est une
performance physique et athlétique hors
du commun un mois ce qui m'a fait rire
mais je pense que c'est aussi vous
autour de la table c'est quand même la
réaction de ce monsieur qui dit en gros
je regarde pas les dames on n'attend
guère dans un cabaret c'est quand même
pour regarder les dames sur lesquels
sont fort joli étonnamment il y avait de
toutes les réactions il y avait des
messieurs qui étaient là tout droit qui
ne bougeait pas et puis d'autres bac et
profiter du spectacle évidemment
accompagnés de leurs femmes épouses ou
compagnes
vous soyez pas mis en scène
c'était un peu convaincant jalu ans
soeur mais au début on était parti sur
testé pour vous en tant que serveur mais
quand j'ai vu l'étroitesse des escaliers
dans le milord je me suis dit que je
reviendrai dans un fauteuil roulant donc
j'ai préféré être un peu plus sécurité
on a fait une visite guidée qui était
très sympathique qui traquent sans
trois quarts d'heure il y avait en fait
il y avait envoyé pas beaucoup
d'assiettes dans l'évier mais juste à
mes pieds il y avait une cinquantaine d'
assiettes déjà donc j'ai j'ai travaillé
une bonne heure et demie avant de
pouvoir partir peuple murray n'est pas
ce qu'on a l'impression sur les images
enfin moi je sais pas vous mais un
passant par les vaches quand même qu'il
n'ya pas grand chose dans l'évier mais
ça c'est parce que vous n'avez pas
l'habitude d'avoir un à me faire la
vaisselle
jeudi alors est ce cumul fait en régie
est-ce que les chocolats ont été mangés
est ce qu'il est possible de m'expliquer
après on aura reconnu patrick mais si
notre caméra s'est absolument pas
ridicule c'est le lait que les
commandites des cornes non 1 les bois de
l'élan du père noël
le bois de longvic de noël joyeux noël à
tous voilà bon on a vu en tout cas on
réagissait été très appréciée des
chocolats yolaine on a vu un renne en
régie c'était patrick lorraine avec vous
allez en voir des chevaux j'ai fais
idées à prendre quelques risques dans
ces j'ai testé pour vous et j'ai testé
en fait un les répétitions d'un
spectacle de noël à une version un peu
original puisqu'il s'agit d'un spectacle
équestre à et pour cela donc je me suis
rendu au rang national des bréviaires
c'est à côté de rambouillet
bonjour à tous je suis accompagnée d'
elodie qui est juste derrière caméra et
nous sommes situés au haras national des
bréviaires aux abords de la forêt de
rambouillet nous allons vous faire
découvrir les répétitions d'un spectacle
équestre de noël pour cela nous allons
retrouver loïc bourdais qui est le
responsable de l'équipe spectacle allez
c'est parti le dit tu viens me dionne
allez on y va
bonjour loïc alors nous sommes ici là
donc sous le manège couvert puisque
c'est ici qu aura lieu le spectacle de
noël est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire
justement de quoi il s'agit comment va
se dérouler ce spectacle donc cet arrêt
toute l'équipe du haras national des
bréviaires a imaginé un conte de noël
puisque cette année les les chevaux vont
avoir des cadeaux malheureusement il ya
une sorcière qu'à cacher les cadeaux et
les chevaux pour recevoir leurs cadeaux
vont devoir réaliser des défis qu'on
leur a réservé alors des défis non qu'on
aura des numéros technique de la magie
féerie de noël c'est ça c'est ça alors d
ailleurs à un peu toutes les races de
faux puisque dans le round toutes les
races de chevaux et il y aura en tout
sept chevaux qui vont réaliser six défis
je présente notre mascotte il s'appelle
plus évidemment c'est le plus petit du
haut-rhin alors on va lui faire faire un
parcours d'agility un peu comme les
chiens oui on a disposé plein de pas
d'accessoires way et je crois que vous
allez le pouvoir le faire avec moi à
avaler si je vous montre oui je veux
bien aller plus loin on y va
pourquoi
on va essayer plus compliqué maintenant
comme dans les si vous avez essayé le
cabrer
g
versez y est
oh
moi aussi je me suis
là pour mettre le castrol
m
et le nom reste déjà me fait de marché
voilà est
passé de la chaîne à tous ces maux
hommage pour le coup une autre place
pour cette première on essaie de la
chute
louis vous présenter maintenant un
attelage ce qui va y avoir également
numéro d'attelage à même spectacle alors
c'est pas vraiment un numéro l'attelage
mais juste après le spectacle les
enfants sont invités à goûter qui va se
passer au château et on nous a annoncé
c'est pas sûr on nous a annoncé
l'arrivée du père noël alors évidemment
ici voir le père noël viendra pas en
traîneau mais on attelage bombe alors
j'ai bien envie d'essayer de la plage et
bien vous allez essayer l'attelage du
père noël allez c'est parti
bon bah moi je me suis bien amusé et
donc je le rentre en attelage talus
on vous sent très à l'aise ça a été
effectivement alors ce qu'on ne sait pas
c'est dévié je cache bien manger parce
que effectivement dû comme les non dits
des courbatures pendant trois jours
parce que pour monter à cheval les ans
pour remonter à cheval
mais en tout cas je tiens à remercier
également elodie moines dont qui m'a
accompagné sur tournage et et xavier
jaglin qui a monté tout ces images
est-ce que c'est compliqué d'autres
comme ça ont lâché des mains ça paraît
simple mais alors effectivement on va
avoir peur aussi été compliquée c'est
qu'on n'a pas d'étriller c'est à dire
qu'on sait que j'ai eu en fait des corps
voiture c'est qu'il faut bien serré
légende contre le fun parce qu'à pas
d'étriller justement pour pouvoir passer
une jambe et puis l'autre et c est bon
il faut tenir droit et puis voilà avoir
un certain sens de l'équilibré on va
lire
j'en ai fait effectivement un peu plus
un peu plus jeunes mais jamais en ce
qu'on peut appeler la voltige pointe
pour faire lever le poney aux bills tu
fais comment c'est quoi c'est le geste
qui alors c'était dans la veille à 1
australie des aléas levé données et à
peut-être qu'on peut dire une
expression typique typiquement belge
hommes oui à la période et puis le fou
et voilà j'ai essayé de m'entraîner
zapatero j'essaierai peut-être un
rédaction mais voilà dans le cabaret
avec anthony
on
va continuer cette émission win moi j'ai
pas essayé de lever des poneys je n'ose
imaginer ce que j'ai payé les normes et
mirwais aussi énormément de risques on
va partir pour le circuit beltoise ont
fait pas que des compétitions la grèce
est aussi ouvert au public qui
souhaitent découvrir des sensations
fortes sur la piste c'est très prisé ça
ne désemplit pas en période de noël
forcément je me suis fait plaisir on est
allé voir cette société qui propose des
baptêmes de pilotage juste pour la
petite précision c'est quand même très
encadré on s'est tenus par un ancien
pilote professionnel qui s'appelle
thierry guillot il a été le champion il
a participé à de nombreuses courses il a
participé au championnat de france gt
sur porsche au trophée également porsche
et 24 heures du mans historique nord on
aura bien qu'on fait qu'elle marque
allemande bah je cite la marque mais il
a été champion c'est une compétition
automobile en même temps on est bien
obligé de les citer à les sensations
fortes à présent je file à côté
et nous sommes donc avec thierry guillot
bonjour bonjour merci de nous recevoir
déjà tout d'abord ce stage de pilotage
qui proposait régulièrement ici au
circuit beltoise de circuit belge où il
ya une quarantaine d'années votre
société est arrivé il ya peu près 20 ans
il ya vingt ans comment vous avez réussi
à convaincre jean pierre beltoise
d'ouvrir ce circuit qui à l'origine
n'était réservé qu'aux essais privés
puis aux compétitions aussi en fait moi
j'ai fait ma carrière ou avec une partie
avec jean pierre beltoise
puis à ces cinq dernières années et puis
moi je fais dans l'écurie cet épisode
direction ou voulait chacun pour
mercedes et sur porsche c'est accessible
à tous ce pilotage avoir quelques
notions bas à partir du moment où la
personne a son permis de conduire oui
c'est accessible à tous après c'est nous
qui devons nous adapter un petit peu à
la personne
rien que ça quatre roues motrices avec
une boîte robotisée une boîte qu'on
appelle boîte f1 avec des palettes au
volant il fait 0 à toronto mais à peu
près trop beau il faut voulons très
exactement
cordis bastaque ce qu'elle regarde tu
veux aller toujours plus loin dans la
zone sûre pour l'anglais reste le
stabilisé reste constant
or ici redresse bien tendant vers la
gauche
mon seul but la voiture
accélère reste à accélérer
brest accéléré comme ça
super g plus calmes offrir le bijou et
puis c'est bon je pourrais essayer tout
ça combien coûte cette voiture allait
dans les 180 mille euros on va
économiser encore un peu allons à
certains modèles un peu plus cher après
tout dépend des options mais la base en
gros c'est entre 150 et 180
alors aujourd'hui il ya pas mal de monde
encore pour le stage de pilotage ça
marche bien tout au long de l'année là
c'est une période de fêtes j'imagine que
les gens se font plaisir et autres
cesser ces stages de pilotage oui tout à
fait ça ça permet de sortir un petit peu
de la morosité c'est un aspect assez
assez jouissif un d'être au volant d'une
voiture comme savoir l'utiliser il
s'agit d'apprendre la période qu'on est
vraiment sur un circuit et non pas sur
la route dont capote le stoppe pas de
feu rouge par une voiture qui arrivait
en sens inverse donc c'est vraiment les
circuits sont vraiment faits pour
exploiter en toute sécurité ce type de
voiture merci donc aux responsables de
pilotage passion qui nous ont accueillis
ici sur ce circuit à beltoise on vous
avez vu j'ai remis le casque et un petit
bonus on va retourner sur le circuit
mais cette fois ci c'est thierry qui va
conduire à plus tard
ça
il
moi je descends plus vous plaît
super merci beaucoup
ah oui effectivement ça va vite vous
faisait dont il serait tombe bien on va
pas si vite que ça ça va vite mais on va
passer vite le circuit peut-être un
petit peu petit pour pousser les
voitures passer par des voitures aller
très très vite parce qu'on a des choses
dans les chicanes voilà dans le petit
virage c'était du très petit 200 km
heure à trois fois rien
mille euros mais on voit ça sur
l'expression non parce que trois
semaines 8 aux 100 km ça va très vite
oui ce sont des beaux joujoux au niveau
de l'appréciation des distances c'était
plus compliqué que balle rouler avec
votre voiture traditionnelle magie
savoir il faut il faut savoir que le
circuit déjà été parfait en fait s'il
avait juste un petit peu plus donc ça
glisse et juste ce qu'il fallait pour
faire les petits dérapages par contre le
moniteur la trouvais que j'avais pas
assez vite donc il passait son temps
m'appuyer sur la jambe ont accéléré moi
j'avais très peur d'accélérer trop et de
devoir reculer et de partir en tête à
queue mais il a dit non non puis vous
avez un bon casque oui
alors tu vois tout de suite expliqué ce
cas ce n'est pas choisi je remercie la
cct dans le jaguar accueilli parce que
franchement s'adapter en revanche je ne
remercie pas la société pour chauny case
les airs mais petit verre ou alors j'ai
la grosse tête merci
olivier voulait poser les questions
dans ce sens le prix les tarifs les
tarifs c'était c'est la société nous
accueillir gratuitement c'est au salon
les prix des palais les prix les prix
sont très très large entre ça dépend du
nombre de tours de piste en fait si on
fait deux trois tours de piste ça coûte
dans la soixantaine d'euros 6,1 baptême
avec le pilote confirmé thierry là ça
peut monter beaucoup plus haut et après
ils font des stages sont des longue
longue longue durée c'est plusieurs
milliers d'euros mais là c'est pour les
clubs professionnels
même pas peur du tout vraiment est-ce
qu'on peut choisir sa voiture sur un
professeur c'est pour les italiennes
moi j'ai choisi revoilà il faut choisir
il y avait un cheval cabré
à l'arrivée c'est qu'après
on va maintenant passer à clerc et oui
on me dit rien bon alors il faut - ou
disons rien comme dans les cas de noël
je préfère crise on peut juste dire une
chose c'est que moi aussi comme il le
prie de me suis fait plaisir on va lever
les yeux de les comprendre c'est parti
bonjour pour cette suite spéciale fait
je vous emmène dans l'aérodrome de
toussus le noble je vais tester pour
vous le pilotage d'avion un cadeau assez
original pour les fêtes alors je ne
connais absolument rien mais quand je
vois ce ciel bleu je me dis que j'ai
hâte de me retrouver
qui
anthony votre instructeur enchanté après
vous voilà la seule briché
dalo décoller donc de l'aéroport de tout
ce qui est situé ici
meilleurs pilotes le dessinateur
rassure
voici notre top noir
avant de s'installer on va faire
demi-tour avion pour vérifier que
les bords d'attaqué soit en bon état qui
est la quantité d'essence
correct
exactement
on va tous vérifiés a priori tout marche
je suis pas une pro mais je fais
confiance à anthony alors on va décoller
ok
pour les blancs
tombeur de bordeaux torres angola pour
un vol blue air
tout à fait on accueillera km un
parcours bien qu'aucun
avion sur les deux
cantons dans des bus
s'est bâti
à
voilà
après les patrons langues et chialer la
ligue des champions ils s'inventent
des leucatois ne pas rater
quand on aime
on attendait tous les sens branche on se
détruit de vote
de très bien
poursuit
nous voilà entrés merci pour le vol là
on va écouter très bien vu que c'est pas
si compliqué ça en tout cas en vol on
n'a pas de leçon plutôt positive
assortie alors y'a plus qu'à venir chez
nous maintenant d'accord merci beaucoup
d'ailleurs et voilà c'est fini pour ce
vol d'initiation 20 minutes dans les
airs un très bon souvenir et la
prochaine fois je m'attaque à l'hélico
alors rendez vous est déjà pris pour
l'hélico pas encore vous pouvez
effectivement très plaisir sur cette
séquence et oui c'est un très très bon
moment je remercie d'ailleurs anthony vg
qui est l'instructeur d'airé compagnie
qui a qui m'a emmené du coup dans le
ciel ça me vois que ça sourit mais c'est
sérieux ah oui alors d'ailleurs ouvert
moi que j'arrive il ya vraiment les yeux
rivés où il surveille ça de près quand
c'est comme une auto-école finalement en
fait il a également les pédales il a
également freiné ces gens 1900 voilà
tout est de coordonner et ce qu'on ne
voit pas également ici dans ce reportage
et c'est qu'il ya pas mal d'étapes avant
de décoller pendant l'atterrissage et
c'est de combien de temps où tout le
temps une heure et demie en tour entre
le brief et jusqu'à l'atterrissage et
j'avais vraiment les commandes j'ai
vraiment eu les commandes en mars
alors ça fait peur ça fait pas peur non
non c'est très très plaisant parce que
ça coûte cher vous éclaire le côté comme
un monsieur charmant voilà ça coûte 180
euros pour ce vol d'initiation
ils y ont une envie qui dure
généralement antonymes indiqué qu'il ya
à peu près 5% qui ensuite parce que pas
et se décide à prendre des cours à
passer leur brevet là du coup le prix un
peu plus élevé c'est plutôt aux
alentours de 6000 euros et je présume
que la vue qu'on ait de là haut up it ça
doit être juste alors c'est pas moi
c'est bluffant j'ai d'ailleurs ça rend
peut-être pas aussi bien que ce que j'ai
vécu mais en effet c'était très très
joli avec une très jolie brune surtout
le paysage on va maintenant partir du
côté de la patinoire de rambouillet je
vais chercher un lien mais j'ai pas
trouvé donc du coup on va pas refaire
tout simplement dû couper sa patinoire
de rambouillet avec violaine notamment
et puis et me dit regarde ça
sur cette patinoire installée à
rambouillet nolan accompagnée de sa
maman fait ses tout premiers pas sur la
glace
ça fait du papa glace avec mais ce n'est
pas moi c'est super surtout qui est de
la partie pour le petit oui c'est un peu
protégés
sacha lui a préféré laisser tomber les
patins après plusieurs chutes il s'est
plutôt résignés à regarder les copains
je tombais une quinzaine de fois c'est
marrant mais un moment où il faut
arrêtez moi si ça fait mal mais c'était
non
avec une vingtaine de bénévoles jacques
fait fonctionner cette patinoire depuis
maintenant six ans à l'occasion des
fêtes voilà ami qu'est ce que t'en as
pensé c'est sympa je suis pas très
stable mais en travaillant pour y
arriver bon en tout cas si comme nous
vous voulez venir ici la patinoire de
rambouillet c'est tous les jours
jusqu'au 5 janvier jusqu'à 19 heures on
s'y remet emilie
c'est comme ça qu'on va terminer les
missions spéciales us 7 8 7 8 noël j'ai
découvrir sur notre antenne jusqu'à
jusqu'au 2 janvier puisque l'actuel
revient le 2 janvier ainsi que tous vos
magazines vous retrouverez les
journalistes autour de cette table si
bien d'enfiler caudan équilibre dans
check up dans le 7-8 sport dont il
risque également le classe g et je
l'appuie s'est pendu catherine en fait
on se retrouve dans les municipales
votre émission on
va penser d'abord votre pensée d'abord
enfin merci effectivement à tous les
journalistes qui étaient présents autour
de cette table merci d'avoir participé à
cette émission de fait merci pour bouger
et espérer qu'ils étaient tous
différents les uns des autres mais qui
était très sympathique merci les gars
non j'ai bien aimé y avait pas assez de
place
merci aussi aux monteurs sand et xavier
romain pascal qui ont monté les j'ai
testé et puis qu'ils sont en régie à un
clin d'oeil aux siennes deux stagiaires
de troisième emilie et nicolas et puis
évidemment on va finir cette émission
avec olivier petit chansons danses une
chance allait passer mouche et organise
une assise vivent leur
el34 vive le vent bible bondir
d'enjeux mieux merci formellement
ap et là on écoute les saint quentinois
vendus à noël quand tu descendras du
ciel avec des jouets par milliers
n'oublie pas mon petit soulier vive le
vent vive le vent vive le vent d'hiver
tout celui belle
si papa noël quand tu descendras du ciel
on vous souhaitez mais le message a eu
une très bonne année